it's 2 p.m or just gone by the clock I
can see so we should start there's
I think we must be core there's enough
councilors here
but um there's a few missing I know
um
I think first of all Julie's going to
read out the Council of good he's going
to read out the
emergency evacuation announcements
because I'm having trouble with the red
so I should do that first
ah good afternoon everyone there's no
plan to fire drill so if the alarm
activates please leave the building in
an orderly fashion via the nearest far
exit
the far exits are through the main doors
of the hall and the storeroom adjacent
to the stage
the fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect your any belongings and please
do not return to the building until give
them permission to do so by Council
staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded please switch off mobiles
or turn them to sign them and the
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the foyer area
and you're over to council Ahoy
members of the public
whilst you're of course entire to the
film will take photographs during this
meeting this could be done without
this should be done without disruption
to the meeting and can only be done from
a designated area in the public seating
please raise your hand clearly in the
air if you wish to take photographs or
film this evening
I should say this afternoon I think
members your voice can only be captured
on the live stream
when your microphone is switched on so
please remember to switch on your
microphone when you are invited to speak
and switch off again when not speaking
[Music]
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and we'll
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
right apologies for Action that's a
gender item one
counselor McPherson and counselor Mason
Elliot Mason
okay thank you any others from members
agenda item two normal members attending
I see none
so that's that
item three to receive Declarations of
Interest
no no Declaration of Interest
so that moves us on to
the climate emergency progress report
which is item four on the agenda
Marcus hotton the director of
environment will introduce report
good afternoon members
um thank you so the the reporting in
front of you today is um is intended to
be a quarterly report that will come
back to the committee report on the
progress made against the targets that
were set out in the sustainability
strategy
um I won't go through the entire sort of
document I hope you've had times to sort
of uh peruse this in involved to the
meeting happy to take any questions I
think the only thing I may add is under
um uh so section five which is on 4.6 uh
settings to send these strategy targets
uh there is a target there that says
about to submit the fully costly
business case for a replacement of
diesel in the council and the Norse
Fleet with hydrogenated vegetable oil
for consideration by the October 4th
council meeting that will probably now
goes to the December full council
meeting what we want to do is bring that
to um a working group of the committee
first for consideration so I apologize
for some some delay there we do have the
figures ready but it's just the timings
of these committees and the working
groups I think they're still sort of
trying to line these together but that
that's probably the only thing I'd want
to bring your attention to I said happy
to say any questions thank you
any questions
or comments
or views the background there's quite
nicely but
councilor Wilson thank you chairman will
there be mechanisms as we go forward for
suggestions from the public and and
other council members to feed into the
plan so that it evolves over time
foreign
from memory there was also intended to
be an annual review of this and whether
that that's the time to seek a wide
review from councilors but I mean I
think generally
um the working group could be opened up
to others to attend if that's the
council hybrids comment on myself thank
you
sorry for I'll just come back to
councilor Wilson I think it's important
that
um I noticed that um
we get an interim climate and
sustainability officer and uh which is
all good because
um or rather
looking at that I have to say that with
Rayleigh Town Council we have a climate
group because we're looking at their
assets so I wrote to the building
research establishment just because
they've got an advisory capability there
about reducing carbon and modern
buildings and systems and all the rest
of it with an innovation park there and
just with waiting for a reply so if I
get a reply from them I can forward it
on to
the chair and yourself Marcus and you
can decide you know whether whether or
not you want to engage Within because I
don't know if that what costs of any are
involved I know at the beginning there
probably won't be if it's just a visit
down to meet with them to see what they
can do
but other than that what's commercially
available I suppose is what we'd have to
go for you know when we're doing
whatever we're doing
um so we will be getting a plan then as
we develop our assets so this will be
built in as we do the uh the building
and improvements yeah
yes I think in answer to both Council
Wilson and councilor Mill the
it isn't set out in here but as everyone
knows I'm all for transparency and for
informing people and being informed by
other people as well I'm aware Brady
Town Council have declared a climate
emergency and I think it would be good
for us to work with parishes and town
councils as well and try and
cross-pollinate as it were ideas and it
might be that some things could be done
at Parish level better than we could do
at District level but it's making sure
they're all
fit into us so we will be looking away
for the public and for other parish
councils and town councils to engage
with us as well but that's not being
done yet hopefully that'll be for the
first Workshop to look at to see how we
can do that
councilor Wilson thank you chairman just
following on from that at the overview
of scrutiny Committee in the past and
presently
um we call external bodies in to give
evidence is that something that you
would consider as part of this group
you know I personally have no problem
with that as long as as long as they
don't charge us for doing so because I
think there's a as we all have learned
in the last few months there is a lack
of resources for social things and
it can be difficult but there are bodies
out there which
can talk to us if if we think there is
an age yes and it might be that they
come to a workshop
to to present there
[Music]
obviously just coming back today if
there are only one anybody you think
might be
worthwhile to have then we're open to
suggestions
[Music]
one of the areas I was thinking of is
public transport which obviously doesn't
come under the district council but it
would be
[Music]
um
I wonder where we could invite the Essex
County Council
um member responsible for public
transport
to come and give us their views that we
can uh time with them and and pass that
information on to our residents as well
yeah just look at that sorry absolutely
yeah I was just going to say I have been
approached by people in the um in the
public that are offering to
contribute to this climate emergency so
you've got Eco Essex and you've got
aesthetic tax base who do repair
workshops so that would be really great
if we could work with those as outside
Partners or however it works
oh thank you Council I didn't get yeah I
think we welcome all support I mean
obviously I couch that with um some
cautions to understand
um how how efficient that use can be
that certainly we want to welcome those
initial discussions with any of any
potential Partners I think it'd be
foolish not to look at those thank you
foreign
comments
right
[Music]
um
in that case we will go to the
recommendations
by our members have to take the
recommendations together or do they want
to take them separately
is that together
so we take recommendation one
that the progress made against the
council's sustainability strategy be
noted and recommendation to that the
targets a satellitary paragraph 5.1 of
the report will be noted
thank you
yes they're all noted thank you
all right thank you members that
concludes the meeting or the business
for this afternoon's meeting and it is
closing out
12 minutes past two
meeting is closed
[Music]
thank you